there was a snail following you for the  rest of your life  if you  touched it  am i  if there was a snail following you for  the rest of your life and if you touched  it you'd die how long could you survive  this is another internet classic you  mean it has like a thirst for blood  wants to kill you it can it can like it  will go to the airport it will hop on a  plane it knows you know where you are  but it's got to get to you and obviously  it just moves at the pace of the snap oh  never i never it would never touch me i  moved way too fast i remember and by the  way i just had this conversation with my  wife in the car driving here she's like  you need to slow it down but if i slow  down then my brain starts working and so  i don't slow down at all if you keep  moving your brain doesn't get to go one  day it goes black and you die